und damit rufe ich nun auf den
Zusatzpunkt aktuelle Stunde die
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die grün und
FDP haben eine Aktuelle Stunde verlangt
und ich bitte Sie jetzt wieder um Ruhe
und
Aufmerksamkeit wir kommen jetzt zur
aktuellen Stunde whrhafte Demokratie in
einem vielfältigen Land klare kannte
gegen demokratiefeinde und
vertreibungspläne wenn Sie alle soweit
sind und etwas ruhiger sein könnten dann
eröffne ich die Aussprache und es
beginnt Lars klingball für die SPD
Fraktion ja meine Damen und Herren und
hier jetzt die Aktuelle Stunde der erste
Redner der SPD parteichf Lars
Klingbeil am letzten Dienstag bekam ich
ich bei Instagram eine Sprachnachricht
ein Schüler aus badfallingbostel aus
meinem Wahlkreis den ich im letzten Jahr
auf einer Veranstaltung in seiner Schule
kennenlernte hat sich bei mir gemeldet
er hat mir mitgeteilt in dieser
Sprachnachricht dass er nicht versteht
was hier in diesem Land gerade passiert
er hat gelesen dass die AFD bei einem
Wahlsieg Menschen wie ihn aus dem Land
werfen will seine Eltern machen sich
große Sorgen sie leben seit 32 Jahren
hier in diesem Land sie arbeiten und sie
haben sich in Deutschland eine neue
Heimat aufgebaut sie haben Sorgen und
Ängste um ihre Zukunft ich glaube liebe
Kollegin und Kollegen wir alle haben in
den vergangenen Tagen solche Gespräche
geführt wir haben die Ängste und Sorgen
gehört wir haben wahrgenommen dass an
Küchentischen in Deutschland deutsche
Staatsbürger über die Frage diskutieren
ob sie aus ihrem eigenen Land fliehen
müssen ich kann nur ansatzweise
versuchen zu verstehen was für viele
Menschen in diesem Land bedeutet wenn
Sie diese Angst fühlen wenn Sie sich
fragen was in ihrem eigenen Land gerade
passiert wenn diese Menschen wahrnehmen
dass die rechtsextreme AFD sich mit
anderen rechtsextremen aufmacht und
Menschen in diesem Land sagt du gehörst
nicht
dazu die AFD will Millionen Menschen aus
der Mitte unseres Landes aus Deutschland
vertreiben das sind Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auf der Arbeit das sind
diejenigen mit denen wir im
Fußballverein spielen das sind unsere
Nachbarn
weil diese Menschen der AFD nicht weiß
genug sind weil sie nicht ihrem
völkischen Weltbild entsprechen weil sie
aus ihrer Sicht einen falschen Nachnamen
haben allen diesen Menschen die sich von
der AFD und anderen rechtsextremen
bedroht fühen allen diesen Menschen
sagen wir als demokratische Mitte des
Parlamentes heute in aller Deutlichkeit
und Klarheit wir passen auf Euch auf ihr
seid ein Teil dieses Landes und wir
stehen aner Seite wirerden Nichten wden
nicht zulassen dass diejenigen dieses
Land zusammenhalten dieses Land stark
gemacht haben dass diese Menschen
vertrieben werden wir liebe Kollegen und
Kollegen stellen uns schützend vor
unsere Freunde vor unsere Nachbarn vor
unsere Arbeitskollegen Frau
Weidel sie versuchen die
deportationspläne ihrer Partei
herunterzuspielen Abgeordnete ihrer
Partei melden sich in diesen Stunden
feigsend im Internet zu Wort und
unterstreichen ganz offen das Ziel
Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland zu
vertreiben und dann stellen Sie Frau
Weidel sich hier in Berlin weinerlich
vor die Presse und sprechen von einer
medialen Schmutzkampagne verkaufen sie
die Leute nicht für dumm sie sind es die
jeden Tag Schmutzkampagnen in den Medien
betreiben verdrehen sie nicht die
Realität sie
sind sie sind ein Wolf im Schafspelz
aber ich sage ihn ihre Fassade beginnt
zu bröckeln das wahre Gesicht der AFD
kommt für alle sichtbar zum Vorschein
und wir werden deutlich machen was das
für eine Ideologie ist die sie verfolgen
das was wir in diesen Tagen in der
Presse lesen können ist wahrscheinlich
nur ein kleiner Einblick in Dinge die
sie besprechen und planen da kommt eine
exklusive Runde in einer edelwiller
zusammen und plant Millionen Menschen
aus diesem Land zu vertreiben finanziert
von reichen Leuten die ihre völkische
Energie umgesetzt sehen wollen mit dabei
Leute ihrer Partei Freunde ihrer Partei
Mitarbeiter und wie wir seit heute
Wissen gewaltbereite Mitarbeiter ihrer
Bundestagsfraktion die sich damit rühmen
dass sie den politischen Gegner mit
Gewalt attakieren aber sagen Sie doch
mal welche Interessen verfolgen ihre
Geldgeber legen sie doch heute hier in
dieser aktuellen Stunde mal offen auf
den Tisch wer die Hintermänner sind die
ihre Politik finanzieren und mit ihn den
Staatsstreich Plan stimmt es eigentlich
her kopaller dass sie auch an früheren
Treffen dieses Arbeitskreises
Deportation teilgenommen haben warum
nutz sie nicht heute hier im Parlament
die Möglichkeit die Wahrheit zu den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zu sprechen über
das was sie mit diesem Land Vorhaben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Väter
und Mütter des Grundgesetzes wussten
genau dass diese Ideologie bekämpft
werden muss und deswegen haben sie 1949
das Grundgesetz vorgelegt 4er Jahre nach
Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges 4er Jahre
nach Hitler ein Grundgesetz das weiß
sich gegen die Feinde der Demokratie zu
wehren und dieses Grundgesetz wird in
diesem Jahr 75 Jahre und ich sage hier
es wird noch sehr lange bestehen das
Grundgesetz und die Menschen die es
tragen sind stärker als die Feinde der
Demokratie es braucht keine Alternativen
zum Grundgesetz es braucht keine
Alternativen zur Demokratie es braucht
keine Alternativen zur Freiheit es
braucht keine Alternative zum Satz der
im Grundgesetz verankert ist die Würde
des Menschen ist unantastbar es braucht
keine Alternative für Deutschland liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich bin dankbar ich bin
dankbar ich bin dankbar dass ich in
diesen Tagen im Osten Westen im Norden
des Süden überall in diesem Land
Menschen aufmachen zu einem Aufstand die
sagen sie machen diese völkische
Ideologie diesen Hass nicht mit sie
setzen ein Zeichen für die
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger in diesem
Land die angegriffen werden ich bin
dankbar dafür dass es das gibt Kirchen
Unternehmen Gewerkschaften alle die
machen sich auf und ich sage der ST in
aller Deutlichkeit das ist die Mehrheit
der Menschen in diesem Land das ist das
moderne Deutschland ein Deutschland das
in Vielfalt existiert ein Deutschland
das wir lieben ein Deutschland dass sie
von der AFD hassen und dieses
Deutschland werden wir verteidigen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vielen
Dank aktuelle Stunde im Deutschen
Bundestag whrhafte Demokratie in einem
vielfältigen Land klare Kante gegen
demokratiefeinde und vertreibungspläne
so lautet die Aktuelle Stunde die die
ampelkoalitionsfraktionen hier beantragt
haben und der erste Redner ist torst der
zweite rednerd torstenfi von der CDU CSU
der Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer und
Kollegen wir diskutieren heute über die
whrhaftikeit der
Demokratie wir sprechen darüber sich die
Grundlagen unseres Staates Demokratie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit gegen diejenigen
verteidigen kann die sie angreifen und
damit die Basis unseres
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenlebens
zerstören möchten und ich finde es
richtig mit aller Klarheit mit aller
Konsequenz diese schlimmen Umtriebe die
wir da zuletzt erlebt haben in Potzdam
auch als genau das zu brandmarken was
sie sind
aber eines glaube ich ist auch wichtig
in dieser Situation dass wir das Kind
beim Namen nennen wir sind in einer
schwierigen und herausfordernden
Situation derzeit und es hängt
insbesondere auch damit zusammen dass
mit der AFD eine Partei die zumindest in
Teilen gesichert rechtsextremistisch ist
in den bundesweiten Umfragen auf Platz 2
vorgerückt ist und die Gefahr besteht
dass bei den Wahlen im Osten des Landes
in diesem Jahr wir an die Grenzen der
Funktionsfähigkeit unseres
parlamentarismuses kommen das ist die
Wahrheit und es eine gewaltige
Herausforderung ich will es genauso
benennen wie ich es empfinde und vor dem
Hintergrund ist es richtig all
diejenigen die solche gruten Umsturz und
ausweisungsfantasien haben auch genauso
zu brandmarken ja das ist richtig aber
das reicht alleine nicht aus es reicht
deshalb nicht aus weil diese Fantasien
von einigen skurilen Figuren ja nicht
daen und unser Land zerstören kann Herr
klingball sie haben zurecht in ihrer
Rede darauf hingewiesen dass unser Land
stark ist dass die Institutionen stark
sind und dass sie die Mittel und die
Möglichkeiten haben gegen diese Feinde
unserer Verfassung und unseres Staates
auch anzugehen und vor allen Dingen hat
diese Demokratie Freunde wir erleben das
sie haben es zitiert vielen Städten
unseres Landes wo Menschen auf die
Straße gehen und sagen wir wollen dieses
Land so wie wir es kennen und geformt
haben und deshalb muss man sagen es ist
eine große Gefahr die darf man nicht
unterschätzen die muss man klar
adressieren aber unsere staatlichen
Institutionen sind stark genug um solche
Angriffe
abzuwehren ich glaube man muss sich auch
eine andere Frage stellen ich will das
ohne Eifer machen sondern will es
einfach nur klar benenen nennen wenn
eine Partei wie die AFD solche
Umfragewerte in Landes oder bundesweiten
Wahlen
bekommt dann hat es ja durchaus auch
Gründe denn ich glaube dass es überhaupt
nichts hilft Wähler zu beschimpfen und
es ist auch nicht stadthaft und nicht in
Ordnung und deswegen muss man sich
einfach die Frage stellen woher kommt es
und es hängt natürlich ganz entscheidend
damit zusammen dass 80% der Menschen bei
uns im Land glauben dass diese Regierung
nicht eine Politik macht die gut für
unser Land ist ja genau das ist es genau
das ist es im
Übrigen in diesen Minuten ist ein
Interview von joskar Fischer zu lesen
der sagt die Regierungskrise ist eine
kanzlerkrise ja ich finde er hat recht
genauso ist es
nein schauen Sie mal weil gerade weil
diese Zwischenrufe kommen will ich Ihnen
drei Dinge sagen
drei Ding werden nicht funktionieren
erstens entschuldigung ich verliere
etwas Zeit durch die Zwischenrufe ich
will Ihnen gerne antworten erstens
Entschuldigung sie müssen nicht auf
Zwischenruf
eingeen bitte was
sagen nein das mache ich nicht frau
Präsidentin aber ich muss natürlich in
der Lage sein meine Rede halten zu
können und deswegen will ich Ihnen
einfach drei Dinge sagen erstens das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat im Hinblick
parteienverbote eines sehr klar gesagt
nämlich dass die Parteien nicht von der
Verpflichtung enthoben sein können
selbst um Wähler Stimmen zu werben und
deswegen bin ich sehr dafür dass wir
politisch alles unternehmen um
diejenigen zu bekämpfen die unser Land
bekämpfen das ist das entscheidende und
liebe Frau esken sie werben ja dafür
dass man ein
parteienverbotsverfahren initiiert und
beantragt ich will ihnen eines sagen die
einz das einzige Verfassungsorgan das
das in Deutschland vernünftigerweise tun
kann ist die Bundesregierung weil die da
dafür die entsprechenden Informationen
hat der Bundeskanzler tut es derzeit
nicht er wird seine Gründe haben der
zweite Punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
es hilft natürlich nichts dass man jede
sachliche Kritik an der Regierung immer
gleich als außerhalb des
verfassungsmogens brandmarkt und zum
dritten geht es auch nicht und zum
dritten geht es eben auch nicht dass man
hingeht und sagt wenn die Menschen
unsere nicht gut finden dann haben wir
es einfach nicht gut genug kommuniziert
nein wir haben so viele Beispiele in der
Energiepolitik in der Wirtschaftspolitik
in der
Migrationspolitik wo sie eben an den
Bedürfnissen der Menschen vorbei
regieren und es führt doch dann eben
dazu dass der Ansehensverlust der
Politik am Ende auch zu einem
Ansehensverlust der Institutionen führt
das ist das Problem und ich rate einfach
dazu dass man dem ins Auge sieht sonst
bitum in dass bei den nächsten Wahlen in
Ostdeutschland die SPD nicht nur in
Sachsen unter 5% liegen wird vielen
Dank torstenfrei war dass der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der CDU
CSU es sollen auch zwei Mitglieder der
werteunion bei diesem Treffen in potzam
anwesend gewesen sein gegen sie werden
jetzt Parteiausschlussverfahren
eingeleitet denn beide waren wohl
Mitglieder der
CDM trotzdem so zu sein dann warte ich
jetzt nicht sondern rufe doch erstmal
die nächste Rednerin auf aber danach
schließe ich die Abstimmung also wer bei
der namentlichen Abstimmung noch nicht
seine Stimme abgegeben hat bitte jetzt
ein ösus habe ich gerade zugehört hat
gerade noch mal die abstimmungs
Bedingungen erklärt also es wird weiter
abgestimmt bis nach der nächsten
Rednerin und das ist Britta Hasselmann
eine der beiden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der Bündnisgrünen sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren als
die die Nazis die Kommunisten holten
habe ich geschwiegen ich war ja kein
Kommunist als die Gewerkschafter als sie
die Gewerkschafter holen holten habe ich
geschwiegen ich war ja kein
Gewerkschafter als sie die Juden holten
habe ich geschwiegen ich war kein Jude
als sie mich holten gab es keinen mehr
der protestieren konnte meine Damen und
Herren
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Worte von
Martin
Niemöller der nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
nach der Haft im KZ
Sachsenhausen dieses
bemerkenswerte Zitat
hatte
Terrorherrschaft des
Nationalsozialismus des Holocaust mit 6
Millionen ermordeten Jüdinnen und Juden
der Konzentrations und Vernichtungslager
des
vernichtungskriegs hat uns eins
aufgebürdet und hinterlassen dass
nämlich die Väter und Mütter des
Grundgesetzes sicher waren und hier und
heute und immer ist der Ort dies zu
verteidigen die Würde des Menschen die
Würde des Menschen ist
unantastbar ist der Kern der
demokratischen
Werteordnung meine Damen und
Herren ich bin froh über die
Veröffentlichung des
korrektivrechercheeteams der letzten
Tage wir wissen seit langem wir wissen
seit sehr langem seitdem viele von uns
dass Erstarken der AFD beobachten
rechtsextreme Netzwerke beobachten
Vernetzung weit in die Strukturen der
kompletten rechten Szene
beobachten welche Umtriebe welche
Gewaltfantasien
welche Verachtung und
Menschenfeindlichkeit jeden Tag in den
Parlamenten von
afdlern formuliert werden aber mit dem
Geheimtreffen in
Potzdam werden nun auch die barbarischen
Pläne einer massenhaften ation von
Menschen die deutsche Staatsbürgerinnen
und Staatsbürger sind klar und
offensichtlich für alle dazu kann keine
Demokratin und kein Demokrat mehr
schweigen meine Damen und
Herren und das schlimme ist diese
Menschen der AFD sitzen auch hier im
Raum sie sitzen in diesem
Parlament sie sind demokratisch gewählt
aber sie sind keine Demokratin meine
Damen und Herren und sie denken
genauso wie es in dem Geheimplan
formuliert ist ein Abgeordneter der AFD
und das nur exemplarisch damit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger es wissen mehrere
von ihnen haben das in den letzten Tagen
bestätigt Reb auf der Plattform x nach
der
Veröffentlichung wir werden Ausländer in
ihrer Heimat zurückführen millionenfach
das ist doch kein Geheimplan das ist ein
Versprechen meine Damen und Herren wie
viel Verachtung wie viel
Menschenfeindlichkeit und auch welche
Gefahr geht von dieser Gruppe im
Parlament aus meine Damen und Herren
Menschen die so reden die so
planenind keine Demokraten sie nennen
sich Patrioten sie verstoßen gegen unser
Grundgesetz und gegen unsere
Rechtsordnung und sie verachten unser
demokratisches vielfältiges menschliches
Gesicht sind Faschisten meine Damen und
Herren unsere Nachbarn unsere
Arbeitskollegin meine Freundinnen meine
Kolleginnen alle meine Ärztin die
Leiterin der kitaitt die Facharbeiter im
Betrieb um die Ecke die Pflegekräfte im
Krankenhaus nebenan sie alle werden
geschützt durch uns alle durch die
demokratischen Kräfte und die
Sicherheitsbehörden und unsere
Verfassungsorgane das garantieren wir
meine Damen und Herren und zwar gegen
die Feinde der Demokratie die dort
sitzen und die so tun immer noch so tun
im Parlament und vor der Presse als
hätten sie damit nichts zu tun aber ihre
Spuren sind nicht mehr zu verwischen
meine Damen und Herren und das merken
die Menschen jetzt sie wissen es und
deshalb bin ich froh dass so viele
Menschen in Deutschland gerade auf die
Straße gehen für unsere Demokratie für
unsere Freiheit für unser Grundgesetz
und wissen dass sie zusammenstehen und
dies verteidigen und jede und jeder von
uns jeden Tag am Arbeitsplatz in der
Kita im
überall da wo wir sind müssen wir diese
Demokratie vor den Feinden der
Demokratie bewahren und
darumier
haben bei dem Treffen in potam waren
auch einige teilweise namhafte AFD
Politiker zugegen und der er Redner hier
in der aktuellen Debatte ist der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der AFD
der jetzt gleich das Wort ält aber
vorhermitt wird wohl die Abstimmung
erstmal geschlossen die noch hinter den
Kulissen läuft ich möchte zum ersten
Ihnen mitteilen dass wir jetzt die
namentliche Abstimmung schließen und zum
zweiten möchte ich Sie darüber
informieren dass es eine kleine ein
kleines technisches Problem mit den
Stimmzetteln für die Wahl gab darum
müssen die Stimmzettel nachgedruckt
werden das wird in den nächsten
innerhalb der nächsten 20 Minuten
passieren und darum werden wir auch die
Wahl länger offen lassen ungefähr 20
Minuten halbe Stunde ich werde das
nochmals ankündigen also das stehen in
der langen Schlange draußen ist jetzt
erst mal nicht mehr notwendig sondern
wir geben noch mal bescheid wann die
Stimmzettel die Wahlzettel wieder
gedruckt sind dann fahren wir in der
Aktuellen Stunde fort und der nächste
Redner ist für die AFD Fraktion dr Bernt
[Applaus]
Baumann frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren
noch nie zuvor hat eine Regierung unser
Land so vor die Wand gefahren wie diese
die heute noch nicht mehr da ist die
Bürger leiden unter explodierenden
Preisen für Energie und Lebensmittel
dazu Wohnungsnot hezungsgesetz kaputte
Brücken und Straßen marode Schulen die
Industrie flieht aus dem Land hinaus und
Millionen kulturfremde Asylanten ström
ungehindert hinein was für ein Disaster
was was für eine furchtbare Bilanz meine
Damen und
Herren Deutschland bebt unter dem
Aufschrei verzweifelter Bauern
Fuhrunternehmer Handwerker
Restaurantbetreiber die Not ist groß das
Vertrauen ist weg alle Umfragen zeigen
das Beispiel Sachsen da ist die SPD auf
7% geschrumpft kommt vielleicht nicht
mal mehr ins Parlament FDP und Grüne
auch
nicht und die AFD ist schon bei
35% wir sind aktuell fünf Mal so stark
wie diese Kanzlerpartei so geht
Demokratie meine Damen und Herren die
Wähler Strafen sie ab die Wähler Strafen
sie ab mit einer Urgewalt die in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik einmalig
ist panik macht sich breit man kann ihre
Angst geradezu
riechen und wie gehen Sie damit um wie
gehen Sie damit um je höher die Umfrage
karlsprache Besseres ih nicht mehr
ein der Spitzenkandidatin der FDP für
die Europawahl fällt auch nichts
besseres ein sie bezeichnet die AFD als
einen dreckigen Haufen Code und die über
10 Millionen Wähler der AFD als
schmutzige schmeiß fliegen ich zitiere
je höher der Haufen Scheiße so die FDP
Spitzenkandidatin umso mehr fliegen
sitzen drauf Pui Teufel wenn die Wähler
Ihnen die Macht entziehen dann werden
sie als Schmeißfliegen beschimpft das
ist ihr Verständnis von Demokratie aber
auch für diese Arroganz wird der Wähler
sie an den wahluhren
bestrafen gleichzeitig verfälschen Sie
unsere politischen Forderung im Kern ein
Beispiel wir fordern seit jeher die
Rückführung bzw Remigration aller
Migranten die nach Recht und Gesetz kein
Schutzanspruch haben es geht dabei um
rund 300.000 endgültig abgelehnte
Asylbewerber und zudem um die Ausländer
die nur vorübergehend als
Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge Schutz genießen
und dieser Schutz endet wenn der Krieg
vorbei ist in Syrien ist der Krieg
vorbei also müssen 600.000 Syrer zurück
selbst Dänemark von Sozialdemokraten
regiert schickt die Syrer nach Hause das
ist die Remigration die wir fordern und
diese Remigration ist nicht gegen Recht
und Verfassung sie ist die Durchsetzung
von Recht und Verfassung s wir sind die
Verteidiger des Rechtsstaats und sie
sind ihre
Gegner und arbeiten auch hier mit
übelsten Mittel gegen uns man hat heute
wieder gehört Politiker von ampelunion
verfälschen unsere Forderungen gerade
beim Thema Remigration auch in der
Tagesschau der AFD war die Woche zu
hören der ARD war die Woche zu hören
unter dem Begriff Remigration verstehe
die AFD die
zwangsausweisung bis hin zur
Massendeportation von Millionen Menschen
so ihre so ARD und ZDF was für eine
hinterhältige Kampagne von Politikern
und Journalisten der abgewirtschafteten
linksgrünen klasse aber die Bürger
durchschauen sie die glauben ihren
Schwachsinn nicht mehr wir erleben das
Ende einer Epoche wir überle wir erleben
jetzt hier das Ende der linksgrün
Dominanz in Deutschland meine Damen und
Herren und gegen diesen Abstieg whren
sich habck und künat und Co mit allen
Mitteln da werden s kleine private
Debattierclubs zu gemeingefährlichen
Geheimtreffen aufgeblasen so jüngst eine
Runde von Unternehmern Freiberuflern in
Potzdam die sich regelmäßig zum
Gedankenaustausch treffen diese Runde
hatte gäer aus der Politik eingeladen
vier von der CDU vier von der AFD und
zwei von der werteunion und was sonst
irgendein Vortragsredner auch immer sagt
oder nicht sagt kann nicht der CDU oder
der AFD zugeordnet werden wie
verzweifelt muss man sein um auch daraus
eine Kampagne gegen die AFD zu
konstruieren wie sie das heute wieder
versuchen meine Damen und Herren die
Zeiten in denen solche politgaukler alle
Macht hatten sind vorbei der Wind dreht
sich für Deutschland kommt etwas Neues
für Deutschland kommt die AFD ob sie es
wollen oder
nicht war das er hat hier noch einmal
gesagt die REM im Remigration dieses
furchtbare Wort was auch gerade zum
Unwort des Jahres gewählt wurde aller
Migranten die kein bleibbericht haben
das sei Parteiprogramm nun bei diesem
Treffen in Potzdam da ging der Begriff
der Remigration ja weit darüber hinaus
dort sollten quasi alle Ausländer und
Deutsche die den Herrschaften nicht so
recht passen ausgewiesen werden das war
dort ein Festredner aus dem
rechtsradikalen Spektrum darauf hat Bern
Baumann gerade darauf hingewiesen dafür
könne man die AFD nicht verantwortlich
machen andere Frage bei mir ankam ich
will es noch mal klarstellen s dass es
keine Missverständnisse gibt die Wahl
muss nicht wiederholt werden es gab
einfach nicht genügend Wahlzettel die
werden gerade nachgedruckt und von daher
muss die Wahl nicht wiederholt werden
sondern einfach dann wenn die Wahlzettel
da sind die Wahl weitergeführt werden
wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten Redner in
der Aktuellen Stunde und das für die FDP
tion ksttin
KLE Konstantin Kuhle stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender der
FDP frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren es gibt ja im Umgang mit
Rechtsextremisten und mit Feinden der
Demokratie eine Strategie die bei vielen
Menschen in Deutschland sehr beliebt ist
und die auch hier im Haus immer mal
wieder anggeewendet wird und die besagt
dass man nicht über jedes Stöckchen
springen soll dass die AFD einem hinhält
und ich halte das auch nach wie vor für
richtig denn allzu plumpe Ausfälle von
Rechtsextremisten und von Feinden der
Demokratie die richten sich in der Regel
selbst und viele Menschen in Deutschland
sind schließlich auch klug genug das zu
erkennen bei dem Treffen von
Rechtsextremisten in Potzdam allerdings
da handelt es sich nicht um ein
Stöckchen dass uns die AFD hinhält
sondern es hält sich es handelt sich
dabei einen Vorgang von dem es die AFD
gerne gehabt hätte dass er nicht das
Licht der Öffentlichkeit erblickt und es
ist doch mal interessant darüber
nachzudenken und zu sprechen wie die AFD
eigentlich spricht und was sie so sagt
und was sie plant wenn sie denkt dass
niemand mithört meine Damen und Herren
der Deutsche Bundestag wird heute
Nachmittag das Asylrecht verschärfen er
wird Abschiebungen erleichtern und er
wird damit einen Beitrag dazu leisten
dass die massiv überlasteten Kommunen in
Deutschland endlich entlastet werden es
ist unsere Verantwortung als gewählte
Politikerinnen und Politiker dieses
Problem der irregulären Migration
endlich in den Griff zu kriegen und ich
sage auch es ist unsere Verantwortung
dass viele Menschen in Deutschland
bislang den Eindruck haben dass wir
nicht genügend Ordnung und Kontrolle im
Bereich der Migrationspolitik haben wir
müssen uns aber klar machen dass die
vertreibungspläne die in potdam
geschmiedet wurden etwas al anderes sind
sie greifen nämlich und so ist es hier
eben auch am Rednerpult Geschehen
neurechte kampfbegriffe auf mit denen
Rassismus und völkischer Nationalismus
in der ganzen Breite der Gesellschaft
hochfähig gemacht werden soll und mit
Blick auf die nötigen Debatten in der
Migrationspolitik ist mir deshalb eines
besonders wichtig keine
asylrechtsverschärfung und kein
abschiebegesetz wird den Rassisten und
völkischen Nationalisten die sich in
Potzdam versammelt haben jemals genug
sein es ist deswegen die Verantwort
aller Demokraten in diesem Haus bei der
Migrationsdebatte auf Maß und Mitte zu
achten und die politische Debatte in
unserem Land nicht von der AFD bestimmen
zu lassen und lieber Kollege frei es
geht doch hier nicht um die Ampel es
geht doch längst nicht mehr um die
Koalition es geht doch bei der Frage ob
wir in einer liberalen Demokratie mit
einer offenen Gesellschaft leben nicht
darum ob dieses Land von einer
Ampelkoalition regiert wird oder nicht
geht bei der Frage der Verteidigung
unserer Demokratie darum ob alle
relevanten demokratischen Kräfte
einschließlich der konservativen
Opposition die Kraft aufbringen die
Gefahren für unsere Demokratie als
solche zu benennen und dabei will ich
besonders und dabei will ich besonders
Henrik wüst und Daniel Günther einmal
hervorheben die das in den letzten Tagen
sehr bewusst und sehr klug gemacht haben
und ich finde das was der
Spitzenkandidat der AFD zur Europawahl
gesagt hat nämlich dass die Zerstörung
der der Union das Hauptziel der AFD sei
das sollten sie sich hinter die Ohren
schreiben wir alle sitzen in einem Boot
als demokratische Parteien und wir
müssen das gemeinsam
hinbekommen meine Damen und
Herren das Treffen in Potzdam es zeigt
dass die AFD es darauf anlegt ganz
gezielt mit
Rechtsextremisten mit führenden
europäischen Protagonisten der
Rechtsextremisten zusammenzuarbeiten und
sich als bürgerlich Proxis für
beispielsweise die identitäre Bewegung
anzudienen und man muss sich nur
angucken was irgendwann mit diesen
bürgerlichen Proxis passiert egal ob sie
Lucke Petri oder Meuten heißen am Ende
passiert mit ihnen das was eines Tages
auch mit alies Weidel passieren wird sie
wird von den Ton angebenden
Rechtsextremisten in der AFD fallen
gelassen werden Krawatte und Doktortitel
sind eben keine ausreichenden
Schutzschilder gegen eine rechtsextreme
und verfassungsfreitliche
gesinung
nach den
vertreibungsplänen der Rechtsextremisten
sollen Millionen Menschen Deutschland
verlassen müssen unsere Nachbarn unsere
Partner unsere Kollegen unsere Freunde
wenn man sich anguckt was unsere
Bekannten mit Migrationshintergrund in
den letzten Tagen so in den sozialen
Medien posten dann wird einem heiß und
kalt es wird einem Angst und Bange und
man kann die Angst die bei diesen
Menschen umgeht wirklich spüren und das
Schlimme ist dass sie genau diese Angst
ja produzieren wollen und dass der Geist
dieser vertreibungspläne jetzt einmal
aus der Flasche ist das ist ein Aufruf
an uns alle in der Gesellschaft uns
dafür einzusetzen eben Miteinander mit
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern diesen Geist
zu bekämpfen und ich will noch ein Wort
sagen zum Thema Parteiverbot denn die
Tatsache die Tatsache dass das
Grundgesetz ein Parteiverbotsverfahren
kennt das zeigt dass unsere Verfassung
ihren Feinden nicht mit Gleichgültigkeit
gegen übersteht aber es ist mir doch ein
bisschen zu bequem ein
Parteiverbotsverfahren zu fordern bevor
man als Bürger selbst das Mögliche getan
hat um den Rechtsextremisten und
Verfassungsfeinden Einheit zu gebieten
man sollte nicht über jedes Stöckchen
springen dass uns die AFD hinhält aber
vielleicht sollten wir persönlichen
Umgang miteinander in der Gesellschaft
doch die eine andere Debatte auch mal
führen es gibt im deutschen kaum
schlimmere Sätze als den Satz der
Klügere gibt nach lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam
ügerorden Selen
dank stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP Konstantin
KLE mit einem Appell an alle Demokraten
die Gefahren für die Demokratie als
solche zu benennen und sich ihr massiv
entgegenzustellen und jetzt die
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser von
der
SPD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Abgeordnete sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren in diesem Jahr Feier wir dass
in Deutschland das seit 75 Jahren wieder
eine Demokratie ist wir feiern unsere
freiheitliche Verfassung das Grundgesetz
es ist eine Verfassung die den Menschen
in den Mittelpunkt stellt seine würde
seine Rechte die universelle Gleichheit
aller vor dem Gesetz hinter diesen
Errungenschaften stehen sehr bittere
lehren wir haben sie aus den Fehlern der
Vergangenheit gezogen aus dem Scheitern
von Weimar aus den unseglichen
Verbrechen die dem Aufstieg der
Nationalsozialisten folgten als
Rassismus
Antisemitismus und
nationalsozialistischer größenwahen in
millionenfachen Mord Vertreibung und
grenzenloses Leid endete eigentlich
sollten wir alle diese Lehren verstanden
und verinnerlicht
haben
in der ganzen Gesellschaft aber ganz
besonders hier im Deutschen Bundestag
der Anlass der auf diese aktuelle Stunde
zurückgeht legt leider nahe dass dem
nicht so ist denn die aktuelle
Berichterstattung ruft eine schmerzhafte
Wahrheit ins Bewusstsein auch in
Deutschland gibt es ja seit Jahrzehnten
bereits Rechte Netzwerke die lange
unterschätzt wurden ihre Vordenker
Hüllen ihre Absichten in schönigende
Verpackung wie
ethnopluralismus oder
Remigration aber es geht ihnen in
Wahrheit darum Menschen zu
diskriminieren und zu Drang salieren
aufgrund ihrer Abstimmung ihres
Aussehens ihrer Herkunft oder ihre
Haltung oder wenn sie freie Hand hätten
gleich zu deportieren machen Sie sich
doch ehrlich Herr Baumann darum geht es
doch hier und darum ging es bei dem
Treffen in kotzdam me meine Damen und
Herren und es steht auch im Buch von
Herrn höcke
nachzulesen im Kern steht dahinter der
Traum von einer gleichgeschalteten
Gesellschaft die alles ausschließt was
nicht in ihre rassistische und
freiheitsfeindliche Ideologie passt das
ist ein menschenverachtender Albtraum
den wir alle gemeinsam verhindern müssen
und gemeinsam verhindern werden meine
Damen und
Herren
die sogenannte neue Rechte sieht
vielleicht anders aus und benutzt andere
Begriffe in ihrer Ideologie und ihren
Zielen unterscheiden sie sich aber nicht
von Rechtsextremisten die so viel Leid
über die Welt gebracht haben deshalb
müssen wir genau hinsehen welche Kreise
hier am Werk sind von der identitären
Bewegung und dem Spektrum dieser
angeblich neuen Rechten bis weit hinein
in die Parteien und vereinslandschaften
am recht R es ist kein Zufall dass in
pozdam ein Bekannter Rechtsextremist
seine Ideen auch Vertretern von AFD und
werteunion vortragen durfte die größte
Bedrohung für unsere demokratische
Grundordnung ist der Rechtsextremismus
meine Damen und Herren ich habe das an
dieser Stelle hier im Plenum schon
häufiger
gesagt und warum er ist es deshalb weil
er diese demokratische Grundordnung über
will mit Abgeordneten die sich im
deutschen Parlamenten zu seinem
parlamentarischen arm machen meine Damen
und Herren dagegen müssen alle
DemokratInnen Demokraten in unserem Land
gemeinsam aufstehen und
kämpfen wir sehen seit Jahrzehnten
aktive Bestrebung die Grenzen zwischen
demokratisch rechts und rechtsextrem zu
verschieben
Demokratie Verachtung und
Menschenfeindlichkeit in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft zu tragen darum geht es
doch hier seit langem hat der
Verfassungsschutz deshalb diese Szene im
Blick verschiedene Organisationen der
sogenannten recht neuen Rechten sind als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch eingestuft
und stehen entsprechend auch unter
Beobachtung und das ist richtig und
wichtig wie sich gerade wieder zeigt
denn wer von rekonquista und Remigration
fantasiert knüpft genau an diese
Gedanken an die den Menschen
verachtenden Rassengesetzen der
Nationalsozialisten der
wanseehekonferenz und der schor den Weg
bereitet haben meine Damen und Herren
kein Teilnehmer an einem solchen Treffen
kann sich mit Unwissenheit dazu
rausreden meine Damen und
Herren
die erklärten Vorbilder sind die
Wegbereiter der NS Ideologie ihrer
Vordenker Kokettieren mit dem Etikett
Faschisten zu sein sie wollen dass
Abstammung und Herkunft entscheidet wer
zu Deutschland gehört und wer nicht aber
das werden wir nicht zulassen das werden
wir nicht zulassen denn diese Demokratie
weiß sich zu wehren meine Damen und
Herren und deshalb hören Sie jetzt ganz
genau zu am rechten Rand dieses
Parlamentes Frau Weidel Herr tupaller
Frau hui ist es richtig und notwendig
dass der Verfassungsschutz die AFD als
rechtsextremistischen Verdachtsfall
genau beobachtet denn so sehr sie auch
abwiegeln wenn es um rechtsextreme
Vernetzung geht Herr Baumann nichts
davon ist harmlos nichts davon ist
bürgerlich und nichts davon dürfen wir
dulden meine Damen und Herren nichts
davon
die Feinde der Demokratie setzen auf die
Macht von Provokation und Emotionen sie
spalten und verhetzen sie heizen Wut an
und sie streuen Angst und sie haben das
heute hier schon wieder getan sie sind
nicht auf die Debatte eingegangen
sondern sie haben schon wieder Wut und
Hetze hier von diesem Pult ausgesagt und
sie sind man merkt ja dass sie getroffen
sind und ich will es noch einmal
sagen die Freiheit und Offenheit die
unsere Gesellschaft
auszeichnen wenden sie gegen die
Demokratie selbst sie nutzen die
Meinungsfreiheit um den öffentlichen
Diskurs zu vergiften sie wollen die
Versammlungsfreiheit nutzen um mit ihren
antidemokratischen Parolen legitime
Proteste zu unterwandern sie nutzen den
Schutz den unsere Verfassung Parteien
bietet um gegen das demokratische System
und den Parlamentarismus zu agitieren
und trotzdem bleibt es richtig dass
unsere Verfassung diese Schutzrechte
garantiert und sie spiegeln leeren aus
der nszeit wieder doch seien Sie
versichert meine Damen und Herren wir
nutzen alle Instrumente die unserer
wehrhaften Demokratie zur Verfügung
stehen die Mittel des Strafrechts
genauso wie vereinsverbote wie wir sie
im Fall der artgemeinschaft der
Hammerskins im letzten Jahr schon
ausgesprochen haben darauf können Sie
sich verlassen meine Damen und Herren
und mehr
noch und mehr noch wir wollen auch die
Finanzströme dieses milies trocken legen
wir werden auf diesem Feld weitermachen
was wir mit dem Verfassungsschutz
begonnen haben wir haben die Kapazitäten
in diesem Bereich als Koalition
ausgebaut und werden dort auch weiter
vertieft tätig sein wir werden alles
nutzen was uns zur Verfügung stehen sie
sehen diese Regierung wir zerschlagen
rechtsextreme Netzwerke wir entwaffnen
die rechtsextreme Szene meine Damen und
Herren wir entfernen Verfassungsfeinde
aus dem öffentlichen Dienst und dafür
haben wir das Disziplinarrecht in diesem
Haus erst vor wenigen Monaten verändert
wir bekämpfen rechte Propaganda und
Verschwörungstheorien aller Art wir
werden daran arbeiten diese Demokratie
zu stärken und wir werden sie gegen
Verfassungsfeinde verteidigen und wir
werden die rechter Gewalt nicht alleine
lassen die Frau Abgeordnete Hasselmann
hat es gesagt wir stehen an der Seite
all derer die durch ihre Hass und Hetze
unter Bedrohung stehen gerade derzeit
sich nicht wohlfühlen darüber nachdenken
dieses Land zu verlassen wir stehen an
der Seite all dieser Menschen die gute
Freunde sind unsere Ärzte unsere
Kolleginnen Kollegen sich durch nichts
unterscheiden wir werden sie mit allen
Mitteln dieses Rechtsstaates verteidigen
wir stehen an ihrer Seite meine Damen
und Herren
die verfassungsministerin
Innenministerin Nancy Feser hier mit
einem flammenden Appell für die
Demokratie es ist richtig und notwendig
dass der Verfassungsschutz die AFD als
faschistischen Verdachtsfall beobachtet
hat sie gefragt die gesagt die Frage ist
müsste man noch weitergehen Philip amtor
jetzt für die CD Präsidentin liebe
Kollegin und Kollegen wenn wir heute
über die Wehrhaftigkeit unserer
Demokratie sprechen da muss glaube ich
für alle Parlamentarier klar sein unsere
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
die darf keinen Millimeter in Zweifel
gezogen werden es darf kein ja aber
geben und für uns muss klar sein wer von
einem Menschenbild ausgeht das
Staatsbürger erster und zweiter Klasse
kennt wer das Staatsvolk nach ethnischen
Gruppen aufteilt der steht in
geschichtsvergessener ich sage es so
klar in ekelhafter Weise auf dem
Kriegsfuß mit unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung und dagegen
müssen wir aus der Mitte des ganzen
Parlamentes klar antreten und ich will
in Richtung der AFD auch sagen alle
Bürger in diesem Land müssen wissen
diejenigen die sich nicht von
Extremisten abgrenzen können sind nicht
besser als die Extremisten selbst liebe
Kolleginen und
Kollegen
aber ich sage schon auch nachdenklich in
Richtung all derjenigen die sich jetzt
zurecht auf den notwendigen Schutz der
Wehrhaftigkeit unserer Demokratie
Berufen ja wir brauchen Entschlossenheit
aber unsere wehrhafte Demokratie sie
darf sich auch in schwierigen Zeiten
nicht zu einer
hyperventilierenden Demokratie
verzwergen lassen und wir müssen wissen
das wirksamste Mittel gegen die Feinde
der Demokratie sind nicht Repression
Verbot und anderes mehr die wirksamsten
Mittel zum Erhalt der wehrhaften
Demokratie sind bessere Argumente gute
Politik und gutes Regieren das braucht
es in diesem Land liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und deswegen will ich in aller
Klarheit sagen Warnungen ersetzen nicht
die inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung das
ist die Lehre aus der Weimarer Republik
die wir dieser Tage ziehen müssen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich will aber
schon auch noch mal zur AFD in aller
Klarheit sagen Ihnen fehlt die Kraft das
was jetzt Gegenstand der öffentlichen
Debatte ist als das zu benennen was es
ist nämlich ein Treffen von
Rechtsextremisten stattdessen ziehen Sie
diese Berichterstattung ins lächerliche
ziehen sich in die Opferrolle wieso
bekommen sie es nicht über die Lippen
Extremismus als das zu benennen was es
ist die dort geäußerten Pläne sind mit
unserem Grundgesetz nicht vereinbar dass
sie das nicht über die Lippen kriegen
entlaft sie als das Ende dessen was
irgendwie bürgerlich sein kann liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich will es
in aller Deutlichkeit auch sagen auch in
Richtung der Bewertung jetzt von Alis
Weidel und anderen in dieser Debatte
dann heißt es ja diese Berichterstattung
DDR Methoden DDR 2.0 das führen sie im
Wort sie wollen diejenigen sein hier in
Ostdeutschland besonders viel Zustimmung
bekommen ich kann Ihnen nur sagen es ist
eine geschichtsvergessene Relativierung
dass Sie unseren freiheitlichen
Rechtsstaat vergleichen mit einer
staatlich organisierten
massenüberwachung gegen die es keinen
Rechtschutz gab diese
Geschichtsverzerrung lassen wir nicht zu
und wenn sie dann dieses vermeintliche
Stammtisch trereffen verniedlichen davon
reden das sind unbescholtene Bürger die
können in unserer freien Presse die
Dinge richtig stellen sie können vor
freien und unabhängigen Gerichten klagen
und deswegen beschmutzen sie nicht den
Rechtsstaat und verdrehen sie nicht die
Geschichte wie sie es in diesen Dingen
probieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber ich sage auch unsere wehrhafte
Demokratie sie ist stark sie darf sich
nicht selbst verzwergen und deswegen
sage ich auch in aller Klarheit diese
hyperven en Warnungen die davon ausgehen
es drohte der Umsturz es drohte ein
Zusammenbruch der freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung reden wir
denen nicht das Wort verstehen Sie mich
nicht falsch egal ob Reichsbürger
Rechtsextremisten in Potzdam überall ist
es ein schmaler Grad ein schmaler Grad
zwischen gefährlich irre und irre
gefährlich deswegen müssen wir da auch
ganz genau hinsehen aber es kann nicht
sein dass jede Kritik an der
Bundesregierung insbesondere jede Kritik
an ihrer Migrationspolitik von ihnen
umgedeutet wird in demokratiefeindlich
rechtsradikal rassistisch damit
betreiben sie das Geschäft der Feinde
unserer Demokratie wenn Sie den Bauern
prototest in die Nähe von Umsturz und
Rechtsextremismus rücken wollen
betreiben sie das Geschäft der Feinde
der Demokratie nicht nur warnen sondern
inhaltlich sich auseinandersetzen
bessere Politik machen das ist unser Weg
und so werden wir diese Truppe auch
wieder
kleinkriegt und bemerkenswert für eine
Aktuelle Stunde die nächste Rednerin
Lisa Paus die Bundesfamilienministerin
ist schon die zweite Bundesministerin
die sich hier zu diesem Thema zu Wort
meldet es ist ja auch ein Thema was alle
Menschen bewegt das Treffen im November
in Potzdam bei dem überlegt wurde
Menschen mit ausländischen Wurzeln dem
Landes zu verweisen und nicht nur SN
auch nicht genehme deutsche Lis
pa Damen und Herren die demokratiefeinde
sie lassen keinen Zweifel daran was sie
mit Deutschland was Sie mit unserer
Gesellschaft und was Sie mit unseren
demok demokratischen Institutionen
Vorhaben ihre obsönen Allmachtsfantasien
sie zielen konkret darauf unsere
demokratischen Institutionen zu
erschüttern und sie zu zerstören und das
was führende Köpfe der rechtsextremen
und identitären Szenen in Anwesenheit
von AF Politikern auf ihrer
geheimkonferenz am lehetsee besprachen
und CDU war nichts Geringeres als die
geplante deation von Millionen auch
deutscher StaatsbürgerInnen aus
Deutschland ein Angriff auf unser aller
Grundrechte ein Angriff auf die
Grundwerte der Bundesrepublik und hier
legt die AFD unverholen nach die AFD
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Ost schreiben in
einer gemeinsamen Pressemitteilung in
dieser Woche am
15.101 Deutschland muss wieder deutscher
werden und bekräftigen damit was einer
ihrer führenden Köpfe schon vor Jahren
fantasiere es gebe ja eigentlich nur 60
Millionen Deutsche heißt alle anderen
gehören nicht dazu dieses völkische
Verständnis erinnert an das dunkelste
Kapitel deutscher Geschichte und ich
sage Ihnen das werden wir
verhindern
hier im Haus hier im Land hier in dieser
Gesellschaft wir die DemokratInnen und
Demokraten in Deutschland denn das ist
unser aller Land wir weichen
nicht wir werden die Vielfalt dieses
Landes und der Menschen verteidigen und
wir werden uns nicht spalten lassen in
ein wir und in ein
die
und da können Sie noch so viele
aufmärsch organisieren mit bekannten
rechtsextremen wie damals in Kemnitz ich
sage wir sind
mehr in Köln in Hamburg in Potzdam in
Berlin Freiburg Leipzig Augsburg
Schwerin und Duisburg zeigten engagierte
Bürgerinnen wie wichtig es Ihnen ist
unsere Demokratie zu verteidigen am 6
Tag inf Folge gehen Menschen auf die
Straße mit der klaren Botschaft es
reicht keinen
den Nazis und den
demokratiefeinden am Freitag geht es
weiter in Frankfurt am Main in Erfurt in
Braunschweig und in zahlreichen weiteren
Städten in ganz Deutschland in Hamburg
ruft ein breites Bündnis aus
Gewerkschaften Religionsgemeinschaften
Kulturschaffenden Wirtschaftsverbänden
und Vereinen zur Großdemo auf am Sonntag
mobilisieren in München das NS
Dokumentationszentrum Theater Museen
München ist Bund und Gewerkschaften
insgesamt mehr als 130 Organisationen
unter dem Motto gemeinsam gegen Rechts
für Demokratie und
Vielfalt und sie alle sie alle zeigen
gemeinsam wie whrhaft wir gemeinsam sind
und wie entschlossen und natürlich
werden unter diesen ztausenden
hundtausenden Menschen auch gewiss
welche sein die unzufrieden sind mit
dieser Regierung einverstanden aber die
wähen deshalb noch lange nicht die
gesamte Demokratie ab sondern im
Gegenteil die stehen zusammen sie stehen
zusammen gegen jene die es auf unsere
Demokratie und auf anders denkende
abgesehen haben liebe Herr frei und
liebe Herr
amtor und das ist eben auch sehr konkret
für alle Menschen wichtig die S bereits
seit Jahren in den Projekten Demokratie
leben meines Hauses engagieren gegen
Rassismus gegen Antisemitismus und gegen
jede Art von
menschenfundlichkeit viel zu viele von
diesen engagierten Bürgerinnen werden
von rechts belästigt werden defiert
werden zum Teil
bedroht das Bundesförderprogramm
Demokratie leben ist der zentrale Anker
für Demokratieförderung und Prävention
vor Extremismus mit 16
landesdemokratiezentren und mehr als 350
Partnerschaften für Demokratie in
Deutschland Demokratie leben das
Programm wirkt und darum führen wir
dieses erfolgreiche Programm in diesem
Jahr fort und werden es mit dem
demokratiedergesetz
werden wir die zivilgesellschaftlich
Initiativen finanziell noch
verlässlicher absichern die sich für
Demokratie und gegen Extremismus
einsetzente Damen und Herren wir hier im
Haus und auch diese Bundesregierung wir
scheuen nicht die Wehrhaftigkeit des
Staates unter Beweis zu stellen wir
werden es nicht zulassen dass
menschenfeindliche Umtriebe unsere
Gesellschaft auseinandertreiben unser
Rechtsstaat ist
währhaft und ich sag en hier und heute
wir stellen uns gegen die die uns
Spalten wollen gegen die die zündeln und
deren durchschaubare Strategie allein
darauf abzielt Chaos und Unheil zu
stiften die Wirtschaft und die
gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt
abzuwiürken das Rat zurückzudrehen und
das mit ganz viel kräftigen Rückenwind
aus Moskau unsere Demokratie zu
zerstören sie werden
scheitern
sie werden scheitern weil die Menschen
in Deutschland haben sie jetzt
durchschaut sie und ihre ganze
Niedertracht und Menschenverachtung und
deshalb danke ich noch einmal allen
DemokratInnen und Demokraten in diesem
Land dies Paus war das die
Bundesfamilienministerin von den
Bündnisgrünen und die nächste Rednerin
kommt wieder von der FDP Linda
Teuteberg
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn in unserem Land sich
demokratiefeindlichkeit
Rechtsextremismus zeigt dann gilt es das
ganz klar zu benennen und deshalb ist es
gut dass wir diese Debatte heute haben
und dem ganz klar gemeinsam
entgegentreten ich finde allerdings auch
gerade weil wir in diesem Jahr 75 Jahre
Grundgesetz begehen und dieses
Grundgesetz im Parlamentarischen Rat
unter dem direkten Eindruck der tiefen
Erschütterung des Eindrucks vom
Zivilisationsbruch der chois vom Leid
das Deutschland mit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg über die Welt gebracht hat
umso mehr sollten wir auch eine gewisse
Demut an den Tag legen zu schauen welche
Schlüsse haben die Väter und Mütter des
Grundgesetzes daraus gezogen welche
Bestimmung haben Sie deshalb getroffen
und sie haben mit dem System der der
freitlich demokratischen Grundordnung um
dessen Verteidigung es hier geht die
beste Verfassung geschaffen die es auf
deutschem Boden je gab und die wir heute
zu verteidigen haben sie zeichnet sich
aus durch die Achtung von im Grundgesetz
konkretisierten Menschen und
Bürgerrechten Gewaltenteilung
unabhängigen Gerichten mehr
parteienprinzip parlamentarischer
Demokratie Willensbildung und
Legitimation von unten nach oben und
viele mehr und wir brauchen ein en
Ansatz das will ich hier nur kurz
skizzieren natürlich des Rechtsstaates
der mit unseren Sicherheitsbehörden und
der Justiz vorgeht gegen Feinde der
Verfassung wir brauchen die
Verantwortung jedes und jeder einzelnen
im Alltag zu widersprechen wo uns
Menschenverachtung und
verfassungsfeindliche Ansichten begegnen
jeder und jede muss sich entscheiden ob
er oder sie zum Kollabieren oder zum
Funktionieren dieser Demokratie
beitragen will
und natürlich Bildung und Prävention
allerdings will ich es hier bei der
Bemerkung belassen ob mehr vom Gleichen
hilfreich ist wenn wir den jetzigen
Ernst der Lage beklagen das möchte ich
in Zweifel ziehen und hier sollten wir
genauer hinschauen welche
Präventionsmaßnahmen wirklich sinnvoll
sind wenn
wir von wehrhafter Demokratie sprechen
dann sprechen wir von einem Konzept dass
sich die Väter und Mütter des
Grundgesetzes überlegt haben und da gibt
es ein Regel
ausnahmeverhältnis und das
Parteienverbot ist als absolute ultima
ratio vorgesehen nicht als normales
Instrument und deshalb finde ich sollten
wir genau daran denken das Grundgesetz
beruht auch auf dem Prinzip dass der
Zweck nicht die Mittel heiligt das
sollte uns Anspruch und Verpflichtung
sein vor einer vorschnellen
Verbotsdebatte die Offensive positive
Verteidigung unserer Demokratie
anzugehen man kann unterschiedlicher
Meinung sein ob etwas juristisch
aussichtsreich ist und ob es politisch
klug ist das ein Instrument aber
überhaupt in der Verfassung steht
erspart uns nicht die Debatte über die
politische Klugheit es ist kein Ersatz
für die Verteidigung Ausfüllung und
Stärkung dieser Demokratie liebe
Kollegen und in der in der Erschütterung
über das was wir wahrgenommen haben
kommt immer wieder der Ruf nach einem
Aufstand der Anständigen und ja da wo
Menschenverachtung wo uns
verfassungsfeindliche Ziele en da
brauchen wir die aber man sollte es sich
mit solchen Begriffen wie Aufstand der
Anständigen nicht zu leicht machen in
der Demokratie gilt auch anständige
können darüber welche Politik zu machen
ist sehr unterschiedlicher Meinung sein
auch anständige können und gerade in
unserer Zeit sehr unzufrieden sein und
deshalb ist auch mit dieser Lage eine
besondere Verantwortung verbunden wenn
wir über Extremismus über die freitlich
demokratische Grundordnung sprechen dann
ist die Scheidelinie die Systemfrage
nicht ob jemand anderer Meinung ist eine
andere Politik will sondern ob er ein
anderes System einen anderen Staat will
und deshalb gilt auch deutlich zu machen
gerade in der systemauseinandersetzung
über die wir auch in Außenpolitik so aus
gutem Grund sprechen dass wir in einer
Systemkonkurrenz auch mit autoritären
Systemen in dieser Zeit sind die
handlungs und Lernfähigkeit unserer
liberalen Demokratie unter Beweis zu
stellen es gilt auch zu zeigen dass im
demokratischen System eine andere
Politik möglich ist und da gilt es auch
etwas zu sagen was nicht für alle bequem
ist Demokratie ist ein Möglichkeitsraum
für verschiedene politische Ideen Werte
gebunden und unter den Spielregeln
unseres Grundgesetzes aber sie kennt
kein sondererziehungsrecht für die
politische Linke und auch kein
Alleinvertretungsanspruch einer Partei
oder eines Lagers auf das Gemeinwohl
sondern wir brauchen im Rahmen der
Spielregeln und der Werte unseres
Grundgesetzes die lebendige
Debatte und
deshalb
ist damit eine besondere Verantwortung
verbunden zu unterscheiden zwischen dem
notwendigen zusammenstehen zur
Verteidigung dieses Systems der
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
einerseits und der Gefahr es sich zu
leicht zu machen und diese diese Gefahr
die wir alle wahrnehmen dazu zu nutzen
auch legitime Anliegen zu diskreditieren
zum Schluss hab ihr nicht die Zeit es
näher auszuführen aber z.B der Wunsch
nach einer rechtsstaatlich
kontrollierten Migration ist einer der
dazu gehört Geschichte verläuft weder
zufällig noch zwangsläufig deshalb
lassen sie uns der Verantwortung gerecht
werden diesen schmalen Grad zwischen
entschiedener Verteidigung unserer
Demokratie aber nicht zum kurzfristigen
eigenen Vorteil gerecht zu werden vielen
Dank auf Antrag der koalitionsfraktion
debattiert der Deutsche Bundestag zur
Stunde eine Aktuelle Stunde mit dem
schönen Titel klare Kante gegen
demokratiefeinde und
verteibungspläne es geht um das Treffen
in pozdam im November vergangenen Jahres
Alexander Hoffmann hat jetzt das Wort
für die CDU CSU sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin geschätzte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren schließen sie doch für einen
kleinen Augenblick mal die Augen
überlegen Sie dann wie viel Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund sich in ihrem
Freund des Kreis befinden in ihrer
Familie im Kreise ihrer
Arbeitskollegin und
Arbeitskollegen und dann überlegen Sie
was das mit ihnen macht wenn diese
Menschen die Information bekämen ihr
müsst per staatlicher Anordnung binnen
drei Tagen das Land verlassen ich sage
Ihnen dieser ehrliche Blick ins eigene
Herz der zeigt doch am deutlichsten wie
sehr diese
Fantastereien aus dieser Villa in
Potzdam die Axt Anlegen an unser
soziales Gefüge die Axt Anlegen an
unsere menschliches Miteinander ja die
Axt Anlegen an das was uns als Menschen
ausmacht und es ist natürlich es ist
natürlich die
AFD die diesen Rechten
Fantastereien den Weg
heute wird das schon wieder relativiert
da heißt dann ja der Begriff der
Migration den verstehen wir ja völlig
anders gestern im Innenausschuss hat die
AFD das noch unglaublich witzig gefunden
ha
ha und ich sage immer Sie tun doch immer
so als werden sie die letzten Aufrechten
deutschen dann hören Sie doch mal auf
mit diesem elenden
schmierenater died tut AFD tut das was
sie seit dem ersten Tag macht sie
versucht unsere Gesellschaft sie
versucht unsere Demokratie zu zersetzen
aus sich heraus mit den Mitteln die die
Demokratie zur Verfügung steht und die
Wahrheit ist je höher die Umfragewerte
je besser die
Wahlergebnisse desto
eher gelingt ihr das und deshalb glaube
ich muss heute klar sein was uns als
Demokraten einen muss es ist der
gemeinsame Kampf gegen die
AFD wir müssen dort
aber zwei
Dinge
unterscheiden da ist zum einen der
Rechtsstaat der sich wehren kann und der
sich wehrt es ist richtig dass die AFD
vom Verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird es
ist richtig dass es die ersten
Einstufungen gibt von Landesverbänden
als gesichert rechtsextrem und wenn das
am Ende weil die Voraussetzungen
vorliegen in ein Verbotsverfahren
einmündet dann begrüßen wir als Union
das
ausdrücklich aber ich sage Ihnen es ist
doch zu wenig wenn jetzt vor allem der
Partei die parteilandschaft und der
parlamentarische Raum sich im
wesentlichen auf das Thema
Parteienverbot
reduziert denn es sind die Parteien und
es sind die Parlamentarier die eine
Politik machen können die der AFD die
identitätsstiftenden Themen wie gerade
Migration wegnehmen
könnten beispiele gibt es genug gehen
Sie zurück in die 90er Jahre die
flüchtlingswähle aus dem
Jugoslawienkrieg und auch dort war so
wie die etablierte Politik Antworten
gefunden hat hatte der rechte Spuk ein
Ende und mit
Verlaub es ist halt nicht nur so dass es
die amtierende Regierung leider
unterlässt eine Politik zu machen die
der Ampel die identitätstiftenden Themen
wegnimmt sondern sie machen und das muss
ich Ihnen sagen an mancher Stelle eine
Politik die die Menschen in Scharen in
die Arme der AFD TR schauen Sie sich die
Debatte um das heizungsgesetz an die
Ohnmacht die dort Menschen empfunden
haben weil sie etwas übergestü
haben hat am Ende zu einem Anwachsen der
AFD umfrageerte geführt Frau
bundesinnenministerin morgen wollen sie
das
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht durch dieses
Parlament
Boxen völlig aus der Zeit gefallen ohne
inhaltliche Notwendigkeit senken Sie
jetzt die Anforderungen ab in einer Zeit
wo wir
rekordzuwanderungszahlen haben und auch
da senden sie wieder das falsche Signal
aus und ich sage Ihnen wenn Sie eine
Politik machen wollen die der AFD die
identitätstiften Themen wegnimmt dann
haben sie uns an Ihrer Seite wenn Sie
aber nur über Verbotsverfahren reden
wollen dann bedienen sie am Ende das
narrativ der AFD weil die AFD dadurch in
die Opferrolle kommt und es zeigt am
Ende dass sie unter Umständen zu hilflos
sind um die richtige Politik zu machen
vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
die nächste Rednerin kommt von der SPD
güllestin jüchel von der SPD sie im
Ausschuss für
Inneres sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich stehe
vor ihnen mit einem schweren Herzen und
einer großen Sorge unsere Demokratie ist
in Gefahr diese diese Gefahr wird immer
deutlicher sichtbar immer konkreter und
immer größer die Recherchen von
Korrektiv über den sogenannten
Geheimplan gegen Deutschland sind
alarmierend
Verfassungsfeinde hochrandige AFD
Politiker Mitglieder der werteunion
bleiben sie mal ganz ruhig Neonazis und
finanzstarke Unternehmer trafen sich um
die Vertreibung von Millionen von
Menschen in Deutsch zu planen betroffen
waren auch über 12 Millionen deutsche
Staatsbürger die unter einer AFD
Regierung abgeschieben werden können
auch ich würde vertrieben zum einem
wegen meiner
Migrationsgeschichte und zum anderen
weil ich hier ganz offensichtlich einen
der rechtsradikalen unliebsamen
Meinungen kund
tu die Berichte zeigen worauf wir schon
lange verweisen AFD Tiefe braune
Abgründe unter dem Mantel der
Bürgerlichkeit wir dürfen ihre Ausreden
nicht glauben wir müssen diese Gefahr
ernst nehmen die die neue Rechte und ihr
parlamentarischer Arm für unser Land
bedeutet meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren die Demokratie ist kein
Selbstläufer sie ist nicht für die
Ewigkeit garantiert wenn Faschisten bei
Geheimtreffen die Würde des Menschen und
unsere Verfassung unterlaufen wenn Sie
die Deportation von Menschen planen und
wenn Rechtspopulisten diese deportations
Pläne als Remigration verharmlosen dann
ist es allerhöchste Zeit aufzustehen und
der Gefahr ins Auge zu
sehen dann ist es Zeit auch unsere
Demokratie zu
verteidigen unsere Demokratie gibt uns
dafür die nötigen Instrumente an die
handsere Aufgabe ist es diese
Instrumente entschlossen zu nutzen
konkret heißt dies wir müssen alle
Mittel prüfen die uns das Grundgesetz an
die Hand gibt dazu gehört auch die Frage
ob die Voraussetzungen eines
Parteiverbotsverfahren gegen die AFD
vorliegen das gilt insbesondere im
Hinblick auf die Landesverbände die als
gesichert rechtsextrem
gelten auch darüber hinaus muss es
spürbare Konsequenzen haben wenn unsere
demokratischen Grundwerte bedoh W Hass
ist keine
Meinung faschistische Bestrebungen sind
ein Fall für den Verfassungsschutz und
die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren so wichtig
unsere demokratischen Institutionen sind
so klar ist auch die Verteidigung der
Demokratie ist nicht allein Sache
unserer Sicherheitsbehörden und der
Justiz es ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe und jede
und jeder ist gefragt die Gespräche zu
suchen und die Fakten klar zu benennen
auf der Straße genau wie wie in den
sozialen
Medien wir dürfen niemanden aus der
Pflicht lassen denn wer heute noch
glaubt er sei Protestwähler spielt mit
den demokratischen und freiheitlichen
Werten unserer Gesellschaft wir müssen
diesen Kampf für die Demokratie deshalb
gemeinsam führen ich bin sehr froh dass
viele Menschen genau das tun bundesweit
erheben sie ihre Stimme und gehen für
unsere Demokratie auf die Straße dafür
gebührt ihn unser herzlicher
Dank sie zeigen so dass sie wehrhafte
DemokratInnen und Demokraten sind und
sie fordern zurecht keine Toleranz
gegenüber den Feinden der
Demokratie keine Toleranz gegenüber
extremen Bestrebungen keine Toleranz
gegenüber
menschenfndlichkeit mit Ihrer Erlaubnis
frau Präsidentin möchte ich mit einem
Zitat meine Rede beenden es stammt von
der Holocaust Überlebenden Margot
Friedländer mit Blick auf den aktuellen
Antisemitismus in unserem Land sagte sie
ich
zitiere so hat es damals auch
angefangen ich sage nur wir müssen
vorsichtig sein es darf nicht wieder
geschehen was war vielen
Dank aktuelle Stunde im Deutschen
Bundestag wehrhafte Demokratie gegen
demokratiefeinde und vertreibungspläne
Sie darüber informieren dass die Wahlen
wieder aufgenommen werden können
fortgeführt werden können und
wir werden die Wahlen geöffnet lassen
bis
16:30
uh ja das ist auch eine interessante
Sache es gab nicht genügend Stimmkarten
so habe ich zumindest verstanden die
mussten nachgedruckt werden deswegen ist
die Wahl die längst hätte abgeschlossen
sein sollen für die Stellvertreter
Positionen und andere immer noch zugange
Martina Renner jetzt fraktionslos von
der
linkenchaft es zeigt die Protagonisten
des aufkommenden Faschismus ich bin
keine Freundin von Geschichte wiederholt
sich das heißt aber wiederum nicht dass
man Fehler ein zweites Mal
macht wenn es um den Griff der AFD nach
der Macht geht sind wir gut beraten auf
zwei Dinge zu schauen was sind die
Bedingungen des Erfolgs der AFD und wer
bereitet ihnen den
Weg eine Politik ohne Verlässlichkeit
gebrochene Versprechen und wachsende
Ungleichheit sind der Humus für die AFD
das war für die
Amte nun zur CDU und langsam nähern wir
uns dieser Villa am See nah potzdams
bisher war es abstraktes Wissen dass die
AFD völkisch ist dass sie einen ethnisch
homogenen Staat anstrebt aber nun wissen
wir sehr anschaulich dass es nicht nur
Ideologie sondern ein Plan ist ein Plan
mit Strategen Finanziers und
Vollstreckern schauen Sie sich die Runde
im Landhaus Adlon an manche könnten aus
dem grossgemälde entstiegen sein
konservative Adelige Unternehmer und
Neonazis warum gehen so viele Menschen
auf die Straße sie erkennen in dieser
Runde die Gefahr und Sie erkennen dass
die Gefahr ein historisches Vorbild hat
und migrantische Menschen in diesem Land
egal ob mit oder deutschen Pass wussten
sofort sie sind gemeint die AFD ist eine
Gefahr für die Demokratie das ist
richtig sie will einen autoritären Staat
aber konkreter und bedrohlicher ist die
Gefahr für Minderheiten nun sagte ich
eingangs wir haben die Chance Fehler
nicht zu wiederholen unsere Verfassung
hat uns dafür eine reileine mitgegeben
die Wiedergänger der Faschisten sollen
nie mehr in die Nähe der Macht kommen es
ist an uns als Parlament diese Reißleine
zu nutzen vielen
Dank
der nächste Redner in der Aktuellen
Stunde kommt wieder von den
Bündnisgrünen Konstantin von Notz er ist
Vorsitzender des Parlamentarischen
Kontrollgremiums frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren Demokratien stehen
weltweit unter Druck ob in den USA in
Südamerika von den Niederlanden bis
Italien in all diesen Ländern gibt es
Angriffe aus der extremrechten Ecke ganz
ohne Merkel und ganz ohne Ampel Frau von
Storch wir erleben sehr grundsätzliche
Angriffe auf die liberale Demokratie
meine Damen und Herren diese Angriffe
werden oft von außen Frau von
Storch unterstützt manchmal orchestriert
gerne von so autokratischen Regimen wie
Russland das ist alles nicht neu wir
haben hier oft darüber diskutiert aber
wie perfide und vor allem wie konkret
die Pläne der Rechtsextremisten gerade
auch hier in Deutschland aktuell sind
das wurde der deutschen Öffentlichkeit
durch die korrektivrecherche
schonungslos aufgezeigt der Vorhang des
AFD
hinterzimmers wurde
zurückgezogen und man kann den
journalistinen und Journalisten in
Deutschland im Allgemeinen und den von
Korrektiv im Speziellen nur dankbar sein
für ihre alltägliche Arbeit meine Damen
und
Herren es spricht
Bände Frau Weidel wo ist sie eigentlich
dass nach diesem aufgedeckten AFD
Skandal an dem einer ihrer engsten
politischen Weggefährten unmittelbar
beteiligt war sie diesen freien und
unabhängigen Journalismus in Deutschland
versuchen in den Schmutz zu ziehen DDR
Vergleiche wir haben es gehört das
erinnert nicht nur an Trump es ist
schlicht Dassel Demokratie zersetzende
Drehbuch und deswegen sind nicht nur die
Enthüllung von Korrektiv selbst sondern
eben auch ihre Reaktion eine einzige
Dokumentation ihres Hasses auf
Deutschland und ihrer
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit meine Damen und
Herren ihr Verhalten das von Frau Weidel
die gerade abwesend ist ist zuud dem
hochgradig unschlüssig der Kollege
Hoffmann hat von einem Schmierentheater
gesprochen
wenn an den Vorwürfen nichts dran ist
Herr Baumann warum trennt sich Frau
Weidel denn von Ihrem
Mitarbeiter ja genau ich sag ihnen warum
ich sag ihnen
warum sie tun es weil sie wissen dass
das bekannt werden dieser
deportationsspläne für Millionen von
Menschen in Deutschland für ihr
bürgerliches Image dass sie sich so
gerne geben würden toxisch ist meine
Damen und Herren
toxisch aber wen sie sichonen Mens
verachtenden plen tatsächlich glaubhaft
distanzieren
wollten dann müssten dann reicht kein
Bauernopfer Herr Baumann dann müssten
sie von ihrem Bundesvorsitzenden der da
ganz still in der zweiten Reihe sitzt
und der an solchen Treffen auch
teilnimmt trennen dann müssen sie ihre
ganze Partei auflösen all das tun sie
natürlich nicht und das demaskiert ihre
Kampagne gegen die freie unabhängige
Presse in diesem Land aber auch die
Trennung von ihrem Mitarbeiter als rein
ablenksmanöver und Spieren Theater meine
Damen und
Herren der Begriff der Remigration den
Sie hier seit langem auch hier im Haus
proklamieren ist klar
verfassungsfeindlich dazu gibt es
Rechtssprechung denn er insinuiert nicht
nur Maßnahmen gegen die Menschenwürde er
meint genau das das Treffen in Potzdam
hat der Öffentlichkeit deutlich gemacht
warum es Ihnen geht sie wollen mal 14
mal 25 Millionen Menschen aus diesem
Land vertre
und zwar aus zutiefst
verfassungsfeindlichen Motiven sie reden
wahlweise von nicht assimiliert oder
politisch unliebsam und am Ende meinen
Sie
folgendes sollten Sie einmal an der
politischen Macht in diesem Land sein
dann zählt nicht recht nicht Gesetz
nicht die Staatsbürgerschaft nicht die
Verfassung sie planen willkürlich zu
bestimmen wer hier leben darf und wer
nicht und das nennt man meine Damen und
Herren totalitäre
Terrorherrschaft nebenbei wurde in potam
noch besprochen wie man das
Bundesverfassungsgericht und
demokratische Wahlen diskreditieren kann
auch das ist kein Zufall kein Versehen
Herr Baumann sie wollen den Rechtsstaat
und seine Institutionen verächtlich
machen um sie zu beseitigen und das ist
unerträglich und nicht hinnehmbar meine
Damen und
Herren herum ihre eigene Kollegin ad
Frau seit Monaten seit vielen Monaten im
Knast general Bundesanwalt
Untersuchungshaft Terrorverfahren für
eine exafd Abgeordnete das ist die
Realität all das ist nicht bürgerlich
all das ist nicht normal es ist
verfassungsfeindlich gegen unser Land
und seine Menschen ich sag ihnen unser
unser Rechtsstaat ist wehrhaft es gibt
einen großen Instrumentenkoffer es gibt
super Sicherheitsbehörden in diesem Land
es gibt entschlossenen politischen
Widerstand gegen Faschisten hier in den
Parlamenten und auf der Straße mein
Damen und Herren und deswegen wird sich
diese Demokratie gegen sie erfolgreich
verteidigen ganz herzlichen
Dank weil heute schon häufiger vom
wehrhaften Rechtsstaat die Rede ist da
gibt es durchaus Begrenzungen denn der
nächste Redner Matthias helferig gilt
auch bei der AFD in seiner eigenen
Partei als jemand der unter
kalismusverdacht steht rechtsextremer
Politiker ist in jedem Falle und er ist
nichtmals Mitglied der AFD geworden weil
er sich als das schöne Gesicht des
Nationalsozialismus bezeichnet hatte
sich mit radikalrechten
rechtskonservativen zur Gründung einer
rechtsfront es referiert ein
rechtsfaschist aus Österreich auch dabei
ein rechtrechter Rechtsanwalt das
hierier des klandestinentreffens
Remigration von illegalen und
kriminellen Ausländern und wo ist
eigentlich ihr Problem wenn sich
Einheimische privat in diesem Land
treffen um darüber zu sprechen wie man
Clanchefs Islamisten Vergewaltiger
sozialhilfebetrüger und den ganzen
silvestermob zurück in ihre Heimatländer
ausschafft Remigration bedroht keinen
Einheimischen mit Migrationshintergrund
sie sichert gerade das Recht alljener
Staatsbürger mit und ohne
Migrationshintergrund die Deutschland
als Land der deutschen erhalten wollen
EU-Kritiker rechtsextrem
migrationskritiker rechtsextrem Corona
Maßnahmen
rechtsextrem Unterstützer von
diplomatischen Beziehungen rechtsextrem
Landwirte rechtsextrem nach meiner
überschlägigen Berechnung Leben in
Deutschland nach ihren verlautbahung
mindestens 30 bis 40 Millionen
Rechtsextremisten oder ihr
Verfassungsschutz Frau fäser musste
übrigens gestern im Innenausschuss
zugestehen dass man gar keine
Gesprächsinhalte des geheimtreffens
kennt BN Höcker wollen sie die
feinemokraten in diesem Hause ochlo ch
die Grundrechte entziehen die AFD wollen
sie verbieten wenn sie es jetzt wenn Sie
jetzt noch die Wahlen abschaffen dann
haben sie ja gar keine Probleme mehr in
diesem Land dann ist ihre Demokratie
gerettet vol den Aktivisten Martin sner
wollen sie mit einer Einreisesperre
belegen wie es gestern im innausschluss
thematisiert wurde ich würde Martin
selner Raten an der Grenze einfach laut
Asyl zu rufen dann kriegt er von ihnen
Bürgergeld und Staatsbürgerschaft es
wird jedoch der
man ihre Geheimtreffen im
bundeskanzleram offenlet ihren
zerstörerischen Geheimplan zuen
Deutschlands und so
funktioniertrhafte Demokratie vielen
Dank das freundliche Gesicht des
Nationalsozialismus Matthias Helfrich
das sag nicht ich über ihn das hat er
über sich selber gesagt und wurde
daraufhin nicht Mitglied in der AFD
Fraktion am Anfang der Legislaturperiode
war das St Fraktionschef der FDP ist der
letzte Redner fr Präsidentin meine der
SPD natürlich meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren am Ende der Debatte möchte
ich der AFD danke sagen ich möchte der
AFD Danke sagen für die aktive Teilnahme
an der Zusammenkunft in Potsdam weil sie
den Vorhang geöffnet hat weil sie den
Vorhang geöffnet hat für einen Blick auf
den braunen Sumpf der sich hier auf der
rechten Seite zeigt ein brauner Sumpf
aus rechtsextrem AFD identitärer
Bewegung werteunion junge alternative
rechten Burschenschaften und sogenanntem
Adel bei uns im Land der bis heute noch
nicht verkraftet hat dass wir in einer
Republik Leben und darum möchte ich am
Ende dieser aktuellen Stunde einmal die
Möglichkeit nutzen auf die 23,5
Millionen Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund bei uns im Land zu
schauen die ein Teil von uns sind die
seit Jahrzehnten dazu gehören und ohne
die dieses Land viel viel ärmer wäre und
die die Sie hier nicht haben wollen die
sie deportieren wollen lassen Sie uns
doch mal schauen es sind unsere Nachbarn
und Freunde mit denen wir sprechen mit
denen wir unterwegs sind mit denen wir
Unternehmungen machen es sind Ärztinnen
und Ärzte es sind Pflegekräfte die
dieses Gesundheitssystem bei uns
überhaupt noch am Laufen halten es hat
mal jemand gesagt wenn alle Ärztinnen
und Ärzte mit iranischer
Staatsbürgerschaft die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland heute verlassen würden dann
würden wir vieles nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten können es sind
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
angepackt haben die in diesem Land die
Wirtschaft mit aufgebaut haben die
Steuern zahlen die hier sind die bei den
IAKS bei den Handwerkskammer ihre
Beiträge zahlen es sind die
Reinigungskräfte übrigens die hier im
Bundestag an vielen Stellen dafür sorgen
dass wir überhaupt hier im Bundestag
vernünftig arbeiten können die hier an
den Eingängen die Sicherheitsdienste
machen das sind alles diese
23,5 Millionen Menschen die sie nicht
haben wollen es sind Menschen die bei
der Feuerwehr beim THW bei der Deutschen
Roten Kreuz bei der Polizei für unsere
Sicherheit sorgen ja und es sind auch
Abgeordnete hier im Deutschen Bundestag
mit Migrationsgeschichte und Gott sei
Dank sind es immer mehr in dieser
Legislaturperiode die Demokratie nicht
abschaffen wollen wie sie sondern die
jeden Tag für das demokratische
Deutschland stehen sich einsetzen und
für Demokratie in unserem Land sich
einsetzen wie übrigens auch viele mit
Migrationsgeschichte in den
Landesparlamenten in den Kreistagen und
in den Stadt und ich sage es Ihnen ganz
auch ganz offen unter diesen 23,5
Millionen sind auch viele kaffeebesitzer
Späti Betreiber und Restaurantbesitzer
und ich sage es Ihnen ganz offen Pasta
Pizza und Risotto das ist doch was
dieses Land vielfältiger gemacht hat
doch nicht diese braune Graupensuppe die
hier auf der rechten Seite sitzt das ist
doch unser Land und das ist doch etwas
wofür es sich zu streiten lohnt anstatt
zu sagen diese Menschen sollen unser
Land wieder verlassen um Gottes Willen
dann laufen sie uns den ganzen Tag über
den Weg das kann doch wirklich keiner
wollen und ich will auch mal einen Satz
sagen zu den
landwirtschaftsdemonstration und auch
die landwirtschaftsdemonstration die
nicht nur in Berlin stattgefunden haben
sondern im ganzen Land die Landwirtinnen
und Landwirte wollen sie nicht auf den
Demonstrationen die haben Schilder
Landwirtschaft ist bun stad braun die
haben sie ausgeschlossen von den
Demonstration die wollen dass mehr Geld
auf den Höfen ankommt die wollen dass
die nächste Generation die Höfe über die
wollen aber nicht sie auf den
Demonstrationen haben das geht nicht und
das muss man
aussprechen und ich will es auch
deutlich aussprechen die Menschen die
gerade der ganzen Republik auf die
Straße gehen sei es in Leipzig sei es in
Köln bei mir Vorort gestern im Sauerland
in Meschede das sind ermutigende Zeichen
das sind diejenigen die auf die Straße
gehen und denen will ich einmal Danke
sagen die bei draußen sind die zeigen
wie vielfältig dieses Land ist und die
ein klares Stoppschild gegen sie setzen
und ich will auch eins sagen
diese 23,5 Millionen Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund ohne die hätten
wir doch in den vergangenen Jahren keine
sportlichen Erfolge hier im Land gab wir
wären
2014 doch gar nicht Weltmeister geworden
wir wären im letzten Jahr doch gar nicht
basketballweltmeister geworden wir
hätten doch nicht die Junioren EUR
Weltmeisterschaft im Fußball gewonnen
auch das hätten wir nicht geschafft wenn
sie mit ihrer Politik durchgekommen
werden diese Menschen aus diesem Land zu
deportieren und ich sage es ganz offen
2006 hatten wir ein Jahr wo wir ein
Motto hatten die Welt zu Gast bei
Freunden wo sich dieses Deutschland in
einem anderen Lichte gezeigt hat und das
müssen wir auch 2024 schaffen bei der
Europameisterschaft genau dieses
Deutschland wieder haben wie wir es 2006
gesagt haben und ich sag zum Schluss es
gibt ein wunderbares Lied der Toten
Hosen die haben 1993 ein Lied
geschrieben das heißt willkommen in
Deutschland und das sagen sie in der
letzten Strophe es ist auch mein Land
und ich will nicht dass ein viertes
Reich draus wird und es ist auch dein
Land steh auf und hilf das blinder Hass
es nicht zerstört es ist auch dein Land
und komm wir zeigen gemeinsames Leben
auch andere Menschen hier in diesem Land
vielen Dank klare Kante gegen
demokratiefeinde und vertreibungspläne
so hieß die Aktuelle Stunde die so eben
zu Ende gegangen ist und meine Damen und
Herren ich persönlich bleibe ein
bisschen Rätseln zurück ob gegen
Rechtsradikale allein das Wort hilft das
ist die Frage zumindest nach der Stunde
die wir hier erlebt haben der Bundestag
macht jetzt weiter mit dem nächsten
Punkt da geht es um die Debatte über das
neue Amt eines polizeibeauftragten aber
jetzt kommt erstmal das Ergebnis des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses zum Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD bekanntgeben der Antrag
hieß Deutschlands Verantwort